what's going on guys this is Rob I think
I'm going to go to the Ultra Music
Festival actually I'll probably do like
Miami music week in March of 2019 and
then I'm buying tickets for the Olympics
in 2020 in Tokyo Japan I am excited for
that
we doing this baby anyway we are
covering heroes in crisis DC's heroes in
crisis event so this is It's really like
a highly anticipated event here's one of
the things to bear in mind guys those of
you guys who are new to DC Comics
whenever a story with the word crisis
gets thrown out of there people
initially like basically you think that
it's going to be like a cosmic event
because historically speaking that's
always been the case like when it comes
to these major Cosmic events uh really
it started with crisis on infinite Earth
Zero Hour crisis in time then it became
Infinite Crisis then final crisis but
you also had identity crisis in there
which was the first time that you had an
event like that that wasn't Cosmic in
scope which means to say it didn't
impact the entire universe like it
wasn't being destroyed or something
along those lines and this is another
one this heroes in crisis doesn't deal
with like the the end of the world it
actually deals with like how superheroes
function and what they do when they're
basically suffering from PTSD and this
is cool because what this does is it
initially picks up with Booster Gold and
there's room no better character to pick
than like somebody like him that's
dealing with you know essentially like
Crisis level events because we know from
the most recent story for example in
Detective Comics that Booster Gold had
the idea to like save Batman to
basically like give him like the gift
that booster wanted to give Batman was
like the perfect life and so he went
back in time and saved his parents from
being killed and that caused all kinds
of problems because then it turned out
that like you know his parents ended up
being killed anyway and so it's kind of
crazy when it comes to Bruce Wayne's
whole idea and Booster Gold trying to do
the right thing and and so on and so
forth and so what this does is it
initially switches over to Harley Quinn
now these are a series of interviews
that DC kind of throws in there for the
purpose of establishing What sanctuary
is now we know by definition from the
various stories that we've seen that
Sanctuary is where the heroes go when
they're dealing with a crisis of sorts
when the the overwhelming aspect of
being a hero becomes too much for them
to Bear Sanctuary is where they're
supposed to go to but it's largely been
ambiguous up to this point we didn't
really know what Sanctuary was about we
didn't know if it was spearheaded by
some doctor somewhere we don't really we
didn't really know if it was just a an
organization where superheroes just sit
down and talk to other superheroes and
that's it there is no exterior Source
out there there's no doctors or you know
no medicine or anything like that we
didn't really know how that worked and
so Harley Quinn's interview here I guess
her talking point really just kind of
comes with the nature of her character
and saying that like she's familiar with
trauma because she used to be like a
psychologist or somebody that worked
with individuals minds but as she began
to go crazy by virtue of the Joker she's
kind of started to switch to this idea
of somebody saying like like create like
these these people out there with all
these problems like we should just like
smash them with a sledgehammer we should
just like get rid of them which is kind
of an extreme an extreme point but she
also kind of has a breakdown towards the
end and that's the cool thing about this
because you see this sort of systematic
adjustment to her character the first
she starts off confident then she starts
to use uh comedy as like a as a defense
mechanism and then she starts to get to
like the inner part of herself and then
she starts to cry and so it's really one
of these like one of these moments where
she sort of it's like her character
being broken down and it's one of these
things where like all she needed to do
was just talk and so what this does is
it jumps back over to Booster Gold and
it's kind of funny because in this
initial segment there was this you know
this Diner woman who was like hey
there's another hero here she's like
that's not a hero that's a villain
that's like well is it going to be a
fight and he's like yes it's going to be
a fight and it's kind of a cool thing
because the way this unfolds the way
that like Tom King does this is so cool
it's like a fight this building to
anticipation because you're talking
about like Harley Quinn showing up here
on the scene and then it's just kind of
like it's only a matter of time before
they fight nobody else really seems to
know and even booster Booster Gold's
aware this is going to turn into a fight
Harley Quinn's like yeah this is gonna
turn into a fight and so it's really
just kind of like when do we strike it's
one of those classic sort of like like
you know Mexican standoff scenes you
know for example from like uh you know
the The Good the Bad and the Ugly at the
end the Mexican standoff scene that
lasted like 10 minutes before anybody
started shooting anybody else it was It
was kind of weird but at this point we
switch over to Superman and we kind of
get Superman just sort of arriving on
the scene for a particular location now
again the invocation of Superman in this
story means that is that we're not
dealing with like small beans here that
we're dealing with a pretty significant
event and so from here we jump over to a
guy named Blue Jay now blue jay was a
character who was originally introduced
back in 1971 in Justice League of
America issue number 87 I'm pretty sure
that he was created by Michael Friedrich
now with regards to to his character
he's he's kind of like Ant-Man in the
sense that like he can shrink down the
difference is that he grows Wings when
he shrinks but the funny thing about
this is that he really just kind of says
like like I can control my power under
normal circumstances I'm very good at it
but as time has progressed I seem to
have lost control of my power and so
it's one of these things where it sort
of feels like he's he has like a mental
block in place now blue jay is a pretty
small time guy I mean he's not a big
superhero which is probably why you've
never heard of him he's small fish but
the cool thing about this is this kind
of you know Tom King telling us the the
struggle of being a superhero isn't
relegated to just the big guys right
it's not like you know the struggle of
being Superman the struggle of Being
Batman or Wonder Woman or Aquaman or
something like that it affects everybody
in some form or fashion big and small
which is actually a pretty cool idea
it's very akin to like Civil War for
Marvel Comics those of you guys who read
that where you basically had like like
everybody from the top of big guys
Captain America Iron Man so on all the
way down to the bottom with like Heroes
for hire who are basically experiencing
this Rift in the superhero community so
it's kind of a cool concept but from
here of course the fight breaks out
between Harley Quinn and Booster Gold
and it goes exactly as you would expect
it to I mean for the most part booster
is able to hold his own but Harley
Quinn's driven by absolute insanity and
Madness and so when she starts lashing
out it's just kind of like look she's
not gonna stop here I mean she's just
sort of lost her mind in the moment and
so what we end up doing is switching
over to uh to Batman to Superman and to
Wonder Woman now this is basically the
Trinity that we're dealing with here and
that really seems to be what the story
is boiling down to in a lot of ways can
we also just say here this is an amazing
drawing clay man's the one who's drawing
who's doing like the art for the comic
and it looks amazing like I would want
this framed without the speech bubbles
like just the just the picture and no
speech bubbles dude I would love that
like that would be that like have that
and frame it in my house it would be
amazing anyway with the Trinity of DC
Comics it's one of the important things
when you're talking about what's
basically a whodunit murder mystery the
Trinity is often times invoked invoked
more than anybody else and the reason
why we call him the Trinity is because
they're kind of like the the if there
was such a thing the one two three punch
of DC Comics really the comic book
industry Batman of course is the
original anti-hero Superman's the
original superhero and Wonder Woman is
the original like you know female and
empowered superhero and so you take all
three of these things and it's like
these are the three the top three Heroes
that DC has but them arriving at
Sanctuary is predicated on the idea that
someone's been going around and killing
superheroes that you basically end up
having like this this field full of
bodies you've got you've got like you
know some of whom are small time guys
some of whom are pretty big guys but
they've all basically been killed off
and so what we end up doing is having
Superman enter into this house only for
us to find the two biggest players in
the DC uh universe so far who have been
killed off Arsenal red arrow and the
red-haired Wally West and this is
actually pretty big because the question
is who the hell killed him like it's you
know doing this is is it's it's kind of
crazy the way Tom King does this because
you could take it a couple different
ways the fact that it's just kind of
like Wally and Arsenal are confirmed
dead like you would think it would be
like a big dramatic moment when like you
end up finding out they're dead but it's
just kind of like Yep they're dead
alongside everybody else it's kind of
the feeling that you get but what this
also seems to point at is that this is
indicative of a much bigger picture
there's something far more significant
going on here the deaths of these
characters alongside all these other you
know essentially Small Time superheroes
is really designed to say that their
deaths are a byproduct of somebody out
there being vengeful or what have you
but they're all superheroes that at the
end of the day Wally West Arsenal don't
are really no different from all the
other Heroes who are out there
regardless of how small they are they
all fight crime they all try to be the
bad guys and they all struggle with
being a superhero in their own way that
they all have their own their own
desires their own motivations all the
things that they regret and they suffer
from and so that's kind of the crazy
scenario is because what we're basically
told here is that Sanctuary was set up
by like Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
as a place for superheroes to deal with
like the process of struggling to deal
with what it means to be a hero to deal
with like the emotional toll that it
takes which is pretty cool because
that's something you never really see in
DC Comics or really in comic books as a
whole and in reality that's just a
holdover from the Silver age that's just
a holdover from like 1950s comic books
that back then back in the day you had
superheroes who fought the bad guys and
the superheroes beat the bad guys and
then the day was done and that was it
and you might see some emotional
struggle in their comics with regards to
like the loss of something for example
1971 Peter Parker loses Gwen Stacy 1972
I think it was eobard Thon killed uh
Iris West and so you know Barry Allen
went you know went out and killed eobard
Thon I mean you have like these moments
where it kind of impacts the characters
but no one's ever really dealt with the
idea of like when the hero Saves the Day
who saves the hero that's that's the
question that none of the comic book
companies ever really dealt with before
and so it's really really cool to see
this happen and so it's almost kind of
crushing because it almost seems as
though the entire basis behind Sanctuary
is sort of all for naught that these
people were all brought here to find a
place of Solace to find a place of
comfort to find a place of healing and
instead they found death and so it's
it's pretty sad to see and so switching
over to to Harley and Booster Gold you
know it's one of these things where they
sort of have this conversation back and
forth and Booster Gold starts making
allusions to the idea and then actually
makes kind of an outright statement that
Harley Quinn was the one who killed
everyone and that's what's so crushing
is it's like you went there and you
killed every single person and Harley
Quinn says no no no I didn't kill
anybody I'm not the one who's
responsible for everyone dying here the
person who's responsible for that
booster is you and so basically we get
this kind of transition to Booster Gold
himself where he's doing his interview
and he's saying like I know exactly what
you guys are about which makes sense
because he's from the future but he's
like I know exactly what you guys are
about I know exactly what you guys do
you guys are an organization that
essentially like the the overseers the
ones that help the superheroes get
through their crises or essentially
robots built on Kryptonian Tech that are
a combination of of Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman's personalities and so
Booster Gold simply says yeah like I'm
here to start talking like I'm here for
help and so it leaves things very very
ambiguous because we don't really know
what what involvement Booster Gold had
here we don't really know if he outright
killed everyone if he said in motion a
set of events that led to all their
deaths if it's uh some villain that
Booster Gold set off by virtue of being
there and talking to them or something
like that we don't really know and
that's one of the cool things here is
there's so many possibilities it's
entirely possible that this organization
Sanctuary will eventually go awry they
will basically see what amounts to like
a small time Futures End where you end
up having like these Kryptonian robots
that take over the bodies of the
superheroes and try to destroy the world
there's any number of things that that
could play out in this scenario so it's
pretty interesting and it's actually
pretty cool and it works pretty well
because of course it creates a lot of
anticipation for the next issue
okay so we're covering part two of DC's
heroes in crisis and as I read through
this I started thinking about something
and I I have a theory and I'll run over
that theory at the end of the video I
have an idea on who it is that's behind
it but anyway so as we know with heroes
in crisis so far Wally West and and
Arsenal are like the two big heroes to
die I mean we know that like like the
heroes in crisis event centers on the
creation of something called Sanctuary
but Sanctuary was a place where Heroes
and even sometimes villains could go to
like get the burden off their shoulders
it was a place for those who have powers
where they could go and basically not
keep all their emotions and thoughts
bottled up and push them towards like a
breaking point because that's one thing
to bear in mind a lot of the heroes who
are out there are masked Heroes they
have dual identities they they really
can't just like walk into a
psychologist's office and say hey Doc I
got problems I'm Batman and I really
struggle letting people know that
because I'm walking this balanced line
of being like Batman and Bruce Wayne by
the way please don't tell anybody
because all it would take is just like a
judge with a court order to make that
information come out I mean they'd have
to give it up and so because of this
they needed a place where Heroes could
go and talk they could essentially quote
unquote confess their sins take that
burden off their shoulders and go back
to being Heroes again the whole basis
behind this was that someone somewhere
went into sanctuary and just killed a
whole bunch of Heroes most of whom he
hadn't even heard of but a couple of big
names were in there you know again the
death of Wally the death of uh of red
arrow of Arsenal that was pretty big
stuff and so this picking up with poison
ivy is intriguing here because poison
ivy isn't so much a tried and true
villain anymore as she is like kind of
an anti-hero almost that she's almost
kind of reforming herself you know kind
of going back to being a hero so does
burley's becoming a hero so to speak and
it's kind of a cool thing because you
end up having Harley Quinn who jumps in
the middle of all this now this is very
easy to write off but it's actually very
very important because what this tells
us is Harley Quinn was not supposed to
be there that she was at Sanctuary we
know that from the very first issue she
was at Sanctuary but she wasn't supposed
to be there that because of the fact
that she is in love that her and poison
ivy or a thing together that she
essentially just kind of snuck along not
only that we're not even really told how
people are supposed to be there that
Poison Ivy's there but we're not really
told if you have to be invite invited or
anything along those lines now we'll
also get another another part of this
puzzle and Harley Quinn will kind of
reveal how it was at poison ivy got
there but what ends up happening is
Harley Quinn is essentially like the way
this is written there are two things
going on one Booster Gold did it two it
looks like Harley Quinn did it and trick
Booster Gold into believing that he did
it that's kind of how this seems to
unfold here and Harley Quinn showing up
at the lair of the penguin is basically
like hey look I need a place to lie low
for a while this is the other cool thing
too this is what I love about clay man A
lot of times in in comic books for those
of you guys who are new here a lot of
times in comic books you'll see
different villains drawn different ways
and sometimes you'll see them drawn in a
way where it's like that looks kind of
ridiculous right like you think of
Oswald cobblepot and you think of like
the penguin from like Batman the
Animated Series where he's more like to
do you know he's more kind of you know
Common circumstance and he looks very
put together and very like you know
high-end and very luxurious that's kind
of how his character comes across but
then you think about what the penguin
would actually be like in a city like
Gotham City and it's like no he would be
an absolute disaster and that's how clay
man draws him and it's just kind of cool
to see you know it's it's kind of
interesting and Harley Quinn basically
tells him look like I have everybody
coming after right now this is one of
the most important parts of the story
the part that we switched to next that's
why Tom King is so cool so Tom King so
the way this plays out is it's basically
like like it's this kind of discussion
back and forth Superman's like Batman
you know Batman's like no I don't know
and Wonder Woman's like you're Batman of
course you know what's going on here
like you know how this guy died and
Batman you know picked it up right off
the bat you know you have this guy with
with indestructible skin and the whole
stance is Will somebody put something in
his mouth I mean if you can't if he's
basically like Luke Cage you can't
really pierce his skin then somebody put
something in his mouth and made him
swallow it and that's what ended up
killing him and it's kind of crazy
because Batman figuring this out so fast
you know leads to Superman and Wonder
Woman asking questions of of Batman
himself like you're the guy who prepares
for everything you're the guy who always
has an ace up his sleeve you're the guy
who's always got Secrets like you use
this place like you can't tell us
otherwise you use this place to spy on
people like sure this was a place where
various people could go and they could
seek out refuge and they could spill
their darkest secrets so they wouldn't
have to carry those around but you built
a back door so you could watch them so
you could see what it was that they do
now this is really nice random one of
them just kind of throwing things out
there and really like specular lady more
so than anything else but it makes sense
that Batman would do that that was the
whole basis of Tower of Babel Tower of
Babel established that Batman had these
protocols on how to take down each
member of the Justice League that he
never told anybody about the entire
Justice League felt betrayed by Batman
and it's like these off-handed remarks
well now you've probably got like
Kryptonite in your bat belt or something
like that and Batman's like that's
ridiculous of course I don't it's these
cool little exchanges because what this
does is it throws in the sharp relief
the idea that the Justice League doesn't
fully trust Batman but then we actually
end up finding out Batman himself went
to Sanctuary Batman goes and sits down
in the chair and see this God Tom King
man it's nine panels long and it tells
you so much about Batman right like he
sits down in the chair and he says I've
trained Partners to work with me and
they've become my family and then some
of them have died and that's it that's
all you get and he just sits there and
then he breaks down and cries and he
says I'm sorry and it's just like holy
it's one of the coolest things
about like people who love Batman will
tell you it's one of the coolest things
about Batman and maybe you have to be a
Batman fan to really be able to grasp it
but it's like this is the guy who never
tells anybody anything it's like this
incredibly human side of Batman that you
never get to see but from this point
forward we pick up with Booster Gold now
Booster Gold is is one of those guys
who's as much goofy as anything else
like he's as much kind of a hassle as
anything else because remember he's
basically a fraud right he's a guy that
never did anything with his life he got
time travel powers or time travel
technology jump back to the 20th century
and he's like yeah in my time I'm a hero
I'm Booster Gold and just kind of like
Hoodwinked his way onto being part of
like Justice League International and so
on and so forth but he's a guy who's
more apt to screw things the uh screw
things up than he is to do things right
and so we're actually going to kind of
take things out of order a little bit
because what you end up doing is kind of
jumping back and forth between Harley
Quinn and booster we're actually going
to kind of clear this up because the two
are separate and they don't really cross
over here but what ends up happening is
booster sits around and says okay so
like I'm probably the one who did this
Harley Quinn tells me I'm the one who
did this and I'm pretty sure I'm the one
who did this so I'm not really gonna
tell anybody that I'm the one who did
this but I'm gonna solve the crime so
that once people find out that I did it
well I'm also the guy who solved
everything so they'll just say hey you
know six and one hand half dozen the
other and and we'll go ahead and let it
go that's how booster that's that's like
a classic Booster Gold thing I screwed
up really bad here but I fixed what I
screwed up so that means everybody will
forget that I screwed up in the first
place
it's pretty classic of his character and
so when he goes through and he starts
singing he's like okay well there were
bodies strewn everywhere so of course
the first thing we have to do is figure
out you know who knows about these
bodies you know he's like if anybody in
the world knows about bodies it's Barry
Allen so I'll run to Barry Allen's here
Barry Allen what's going on now keep in
mind Barry Allen doesn't know about
Sanctuary at least not to the extent
that Booster Gold does and for those of
you guys who saw issue number one you
guys you know if you guys read that you
guys know what Barry Allen doesn't know
and so when you have Booster Gold show
up here and start talking to Barry and
say hey man look I need you to tell me
what's been going on like like give me
the the information you did about the
autopsies with the bodies of sanctuary
there he's like what the hell are you
talking about the whole time he's
fighting something he's like what the
hell are you talking about he's like you
remember what happened man like you know
what happened like everybody at
Sanctuary died and like Barry doesn't
know he had no clue that Wally West died
and the whole time Skeets the robot of a
Booster Gold was like dude shut the hell
up stop talking because if you do you're
gonna spill the beans to Barry and he's
gonna lose it and the whole time that
that booster's saying is he's like I
mean I'm pretty sure I'm the one who did
it you know and so just by connecting
the simplest of dots hey Wally West is
dead sanctuary and I'm pretty sure I'm
the one who killed him Barry races off
like he's he's I mean he's out in the
time it takes for Houston to finish his
sentence Barry is there and back again
and he even asks he's like how long do
you think it'll take him to analyze the
bodies and get back he's like well
considering he's the fastest man alive
probably pretty quickly and and Barry
comes running in with with the wrath of
God and just punches the hell out of
Booster Gold while he's crying and just
screaming what did you do it's so cool
that's why I left Tom King Tom King's
amazing at writing Heroes and when he
writes this it's like it's the super
emotional Barry out because he basically
had the the the the beam spilled on him
by a guy who didn't fully grasp the
reality situation who's just kind of
flying by the seat of his pants being a
superhero and really doesn't seems to be
very Cavalier about throwing that that
information out there too Barry which is
kind of surprising considering how how
much Booster Gold knows about Barry and
so when that information is thrown out
there Barry is an emotional wreck and
absolutely loses it and who the hell
knows what will happen after this and so
picking up with Harley Quinn Harley
Quinn in turn is playing Go Fish with a
penguin which it's Harley Quinn nobody
ever said she was sane so so how Harley
Quinn's playing Go Fish with a penguin
enough set which leads to the arrival of
like Superman Batman in Wonderland the
Trinity basically busts into the scene
and say hey look we have questions we
need to talk and hardly just like like
it's almost like she prepared for this
because she basically says look like
it's crazy and there were bodies
everywhere and just kind of like losing
your mind you know it's just oh my God
it was so insane and just it was just
this overwhelming thing it makes your
way up to Wonder Woman which is a smart
move because Wonder Woman would be more
likely to forgive Harley Quinn than
Batman or Superman because remember
Wonder Woman sees the various female
superheroes out there as her sisters so
she's not going to just automatically
lash out she's gonna listen first but
but this is the cool thing Harley Quinn
makes your way up to Wonder Woman and
when she does she snatches the lasso of
Truth steals it off of Wonder Woman and
in turn uses her acrobatics jumps out of
the way knocks Wonder Woman out and then
lashes it around Batman takes him
hostage and this is cool because Harley
Quinn knows Batman like she knows how
Batman functions where she wraps it
around him she literally asks the
question is there anything that you have
on you right now that can be used
against the Justice League and Batman's
responses you know like like that like
Superman's like no he doesn't you know
he told me he doesn't Wonder Woman's
like no this is you know nobody wants to
believe that Batman's response there's
Kryptonite my bat Bell it's in the
fourth power in the third pouch on the
left and it's in a lead container bam
Batman's a liar lied to Superman right
to his face and Wonder Woman had to have
suspected it because she's not in denial
she's not like oh my god really did you
do this he's just kind of like Batman
yet again more lies more trickery from
The Dark Knight and in turn like she
grabs the Kryptonite breaks it out you
know uses it as a way to distract
Superman and just races off and she's
gone Wonder Woman in turn of course
turns the Superman turn into Batman
attend to him to make sure they're okay
because she would take the more logical
stance and say there'll be time to catch
up to her later which gives Harley Quinn
the out that she needs but this is yet
another instance where Batman is lying
to the Justice League lying to his
friends the same thing as always Batman
lying Batman being deceitful you know
and Superman kind of brushes it off in
the moment but it's also one of these
things where it's like I guess it's kind
of kind of expected you know but like
the statements he makes here you know
it's like man she's good you know she's
as good as you are Batman she's as good
as you at tricking people lying to
people it's kind of crazy because Wonder
Woman's just like this is not the time
for this this is not the time to get
into a pissing contest and to argue and
bicker and so on and so forth Earth and
then suddenly Superman picks up on
what's going on that Barry Allen has
Booster Gold that Barry Allen has taken
Booster Gold which means Barry Allen now
now knows what's going on and so this is
when you basically pick up with Harley
Quinn when she's on the top of a bridge
in Gotham and she she starts talking
about sanctuary and this is a cool thing
because what she says here is she says I
shouldn't have done all the things that
I've done like there's so many things
that I shouldn't have done she says I
shouldn't have let anyone hurt you I
shouldn't have followed you to
sanctuaries like I should not have let
anyone kill you poison ivy I shouldn't
have told you about Sanctuary I
shouldn't have loved you and I shouldn't
have met you you know I shouldn't have
done all the things that led up to this
moment basically that poison ivy was
told about sanctuary and so it seems as
though Sanctuary had an open doors
policy that you didn't have to be
invited that it wasn't only a limited
number of people it was for anyone which
lives up to the Charter sanctuary as it
had been explained so far anybody can
come in here and anybody can confess
their sins that's what this place is for
and so it's kind of nuts because then
you switch over to the Daily Planet and
there's this package they came in for
Lois Lane like it's basically written by
Arsenal saying here's the whole basis
behind Sanctuary here's what this whole
place is about here's what we do here
here's how all this stuff works and if
any of us should die here just us know
that it was done by the puddlers you
know at least the package itself was
signed by the puddlers and so it's just
kind of like wow I mean like there's
these these hidden hands behind all this
and so this is when things get really
really really crazy because if ever
because here's the thing you have to
remember all these confessions are being
made to computer systems and if these
confessions are being made to computers
then it stands to reason that all the
information would be deleted that's what
Batman says in the story no no you know
this whole thing is there people confess
their sins in 24 hours it's deleted so
you can say anything you want to what
you'd have here is you have Superman who
sits down and says I'm Superman I'm
Clark Kent I was raised as the kenson in
Smallville and then I learned my own
history I learned the fact that I come
from that I come from Krypton that in
the presence of a yellow sun that I have
what amount to basically Godly powers
and that I lead a dual identity
sometimes I don't really know who I am
sometimes I don't know if I'm really
Clark Kent or if I'm really Superman and
that's why I made the identity so
similar to each other by just taking off
these glasses and putting them back on
because if I made them too extreme I
would get lost in my identities I
wouldn't know who I actually was but
it's something that he fears it's
something that he's afraid of that he'll
lose his way but Superman just confessed
his identity to a recording device that
could very well have been infiltrated
and could very well have been taken over
now for you know two what happens with
this recording device I have no real
idea I mean it'll probably come out that
their identities are revealed to the
world and so on and so forth but in
terms of who it was that killed everyone
in reality if I'm if I'm a betting man I
would say this is being done by psycho
pirate because from from what I from
What We Gather we don't know what
happened to psychopath I mean we know
but we don't really know the last time
we saw psychopath was during Tom King's
Batman run in the I am suicide story and
like psycho pirate was serving alongside
Bane and then psychopirate was taken by
Batman in order to undo the damage that
was done to Gotham girl but then like
that said like like as far as we're
aware I mean he wasn't killed he's not
dead he's just out there somewhere and
it's entirely possible that if Batman
sits down and Batman says let's create
Sanctuary then Batman would have to
answer the question what do we do with
those who don't want to talk like those
who come here but then they they get
hesitant and they walk away how do we
get them to talk and psychopower can do
that he manipulates the emotions of
others but it would it makes perfect
sense to me that psycho pirate is the
Man Standing on the other side of these
recording devices the recording devices
are just recording devices but who knows
but like I feel like psychopower will be
would have a hand in all this that he
would be that he would be what amounts
to the therapist the person manipulating
you know emotionally manipulating people
into letting all their all their
emotions out either that or would be
like Taco Pirate and Hugo Strange who
were like Hugo Strange is in the shadows
behind the scene manipulating psycho
pirate or controlling psychopower
telling him what to do psycho pirate
does that and no one knows that Hugo
Strange is behind it all there's a lot
of things that could be going on here
and the only reason why I even think
about Hugo Strange I think about that
old story from from Batman the old uh
Steve ingleheart run which they did in
Batman the Animated Series where Hugo
Strange was was basically learning
people's like darkest secrets and then
blackmailing them and like paying him
money or doing in political favors you
know again there's any number of things
that could go on here
okay so getting into uh heroes in crisis
part three what I want to do here is I
want to kind of switch up how we would
normally record this which is to say
normally we would go through the way the
book's written and kind of call it a day
the issue with this is that the way that
Tom King does this is it's literally
like the first page is Lagoon boy the
second page is is Wally West the third
page is like Booster Gold and then it
goes back to Lagoon boy then it goes
back to Wally then it goes back to
Booster Gold and so what it does is it
would create all kinds of weird issues
when we're trying to record this and so
what we're going to do is we're going to
split it in segments because really it
focuses on these three characters on
Wally booster and Lagoon boy and the
first person I want to focus on here is
the segment about Lagoon boy's character
now as he's going through here he's
basically being shot with a laser
consistently but remember the nature of
of sanctuary is that it's designed to be
a place of healing a place for people to
kind of move on past whatever struggles
they have and then go back to being a
hero you know it's kind of like a Rehab
Clinic to a degree but more more like a
trauma clinic now the important thing
about this is that with Lagoon boys
seeking this out on himself initially we
didn't really know why this was
happening but then Tom King goes through
and kind of gives us an explanation
about Lagoon boy and actually draws on
on former instances of his character and
so the sort of uh to sort of wind the
clock back a little bit you know what
Lagoon boy tells us here is that as he's
as he's doing this what he's doing is
hearing the screams of various you know
members of the Titans that he had fought
alongside and who were severely injured
in in a variety of different ways you
know for example one of the characters
power boy was injured he hears you know
he hears his screams in his mind he
hears the screams of like a character
named Barta what this does is it kind of
goes back to the to the origin of Lagoon
boy and then the attempts of DC to like
Branch off the Teen Titans title wind
the clock back to 1998 there was a guy
named Eric Larson who took over the
Aquaman series now Eric Larson's Aquaman
run was written after Peter David and a
lot of Aquaman fans hated the Eric
Larson run but in reality it wasn't
really Eric Larson's fault right like it
was more of like an editorial mandate
which is to say that under Peter David
the writing of Aquaman was was pretty
dark and it was pretty heavy-handed and
so coming out of that it was make
Aquaman lighter and the result was that
in a lot of ways the Run of Eric Larson
came off as kind of campy now Lagoon boy
was introduced in issue number 50. and
the idea was to form a group that was
called the uh the surface lovers I think
it was what it was called um but
basically it was it was Lagoon boy and a
couple other people who essentially took
to kind of like going against Atlantean
ways and then just kind of being more of
like a bridge kind of serving the role
as Aquaman where they were kind of like
a bridge between the Surface world and
in Atlantis uh of course didn't take too
well with the Atlantean people but for
Lagoon boy himself he actually has no
origin in DC Comics as far as I'm aware
he was just there one day and the the
reason why no origin was given if I were
a Betty man I would say it's because he
you know the Run of Eric Larson wasn't
very well received which means that
Lagoon boy was not very well received
now that goes into the Teen Titans
special which I want to say was written
by Chuck Dixon although I could be wrong
but it was Teen Titans East and Teen
Titans East was designed to take the
normal Teen Titans team and then create
like a secondary team that would
basically function in a different
capacity but would still follow the team
Titans brand would still have Team you
know teenage superheroes but basically
you had this this new Teen Titans team
that was formed and then like right off
the bat they go against the kids a
Trigun who basically wrecked them all
and that's the experience that Lagoon
voice talking about when he talks about
hearing their screams and different
things like that being shot with a laser
you know and so on and so forth that's
what he's been doing here he's
constantly doing it to himself and the
reason why is because with a laser
passed through and put him in a comatose
state so on and so forth his idea is if
he endures being shot enough times
eventually it won't affect him anymore
and so the screams will stop in his head
that's the kind of treatment he's going
with here now that's the important thing
about Sanctuary is sanctuary does not
really seem to have any true doctors
which is to say it's not as though they
go in there and then they're diagnosed
and then they say here's what you need
to do to fix your problem instead they
go in there and they're just kind of
left to their own devices and they stay
However long they need to stay until
that trauma is essentially remedied
which as you guys can imagine can cause
all kinds of different problems and
that's what Lagoon boy endures is
constantly being shot with lasers now of
course there comes a point where
somebody says stop I'll come back
tomorrow and we'll continue the process
again but that's basically what he's
doing is literally injuring himself
under the idea that eventually he'll
become immune to it or it won't faze him
anymore it won't bother him anymore and
the belief is that when that time comes
he won't have to worry about the voices
in his head or anything like that now
switching over to Wally West things are
a lot more straightforward here one of
the things to bear in mind when it comes
to to Classic Wally West is that he's
been stuck in the speed force all this
time when the events of New 52 happen
and everything was rebooted and classic
Wally West was nowhere to be found when
rebirth started DC answered the question
of where's classic Wally West Ben by
saying he's been stuck in the speed
force and Barry Allen was finally able
to bring him out by remembering him and
so ever since then classic Wally has
been getting his memories back slowly
and steadily and that means he's been
learning about his children giant Iris
he's been learning about Linda Park the
fact that they were married but that's
not the case now you know by whatever
Manner and whatever means presumably to
the actions of Dr Manhattan everything
Wally West knows has been changed and so
where you can't just run to Linda Park
and say hey romerian and we have kids
and expect her to kind of be on board
like oh that makes sense that's not
going to happen and so what he's been
doing here is basically trying to like
figure out or at least try to find
somebody to kind of cope with his
existing environment and so what we end
up finding out is that what he's been
doing is basically recreating his life
inside of sanctuary where he has Linda
Park who runs out to greet him where he
has his kids giant Iris he has the life
he always wanted and so one of the cool
things is that that he and his kids the
tornado twins actually end up facing off
against Captain Cold and that's kind of
like reliving the memories reliving the
way things used to be now in reality
this is a good way of coping with things
but I feel like what Tom King is hitting
at here is that this can be a very very
dangerous thing and the reason why is
because there is such a thing as getting
lost in any scenario that we're in
there's only ever two circumstances that
we Face the reality as things are and
the way we would like them to be and
oftentimes if we allow ourselves to get
stuck in the way that we would like them
to be we get trapped there we never
fully recover like we never come back
from there right because I mean like why
would you it's like Star Trek the Star
Trek generations right while the movie
was terrible they had this really really
cool concept called the ribbon and
basically if it passed over you you were
yanked into a place called the Nexus and
you essentially repeated the best
moments of your life presumably for all
eternity or at least for however long
your body held out but if you if you
were given the opportunity to relive the
best moments of your life why wouldn't
you take that opportunity and if you
were given that opportunity and you did
take it was to say you wouldn't get lost
and that's the issue with Wally West
here Wally West is living in a life that
doesn't exist anymore and living in this
life that doesn't exist anymore he won't
want to leave or at least it seems like
he won't want to leave and so in
response to that How Can You Yank
somebody from Perfection How Can You
Yank somebody from absolute tried and
true happiness this is the life he
always wanted he has his wife he has his
kids he has the things that he lost that
he wants back so dear but the problem is
that he's not facing the reality of the
situation the reality situation is that
his his family is basically gone and
maybe it's one of these things where if
it had been allowed to play out that Tom
King would have written it out in such a
way to where Wally West would have just
been able to say goodbye I have to let
you go now remember Wally's Wally was
told by Professor Zoom you know he was
told hey like your kids are alive like
your kids are alive and they exist out
there somewhere so while he was most
likely on the hunt for them or will be
on the hunt for them at some point in
time but it's one of the interesting
things because the way this is written
it almost seems to kind of ignore that
idea right like it almost seems to kind
of ignore the notion that Wally's aware
of his children's true existence because
then the question would be if he does
know they exist why isn't he out finding
them so again you know these little
tidbits are kind of you know a little
bit of a little bit of conflict going on
there but nothing outrageous you know
it's just kind of Wally living this life
that ultimately it doesn't seem like
you'll want to let go of now for Booster
Gold his segment of the story is a lot
more straightforward he's a guy trying
to figure out what in the heck is going
on but here's the issue with this so
Booster Gold has always had two parts to
himself right like there's the Booster
Gold as the hero and the Booster Gold
who's a liar the Booster Gold from like
as he exists like he's basically a con
man right like he took technology from
the Future travel to the past and is
like I'm the greatest hero in the future
and it just kind of purported that idea
in the present day the issue with that
is that booster has been living without
lie the entire time and so that's kind
of the thing like like what he goes
through we kind of get this explanation
of what's going on with regards to the
nature of of sanctuary in the sense that
when this issue first opened up and
Booster Gold first arrived at Sanctuary
he was met by basically what appeared to
be monpok hint and Lana length now the
inclusion of them is not accidental the
sanctuary itself was built using the
technology of Superman the Ingenuity of
Batman and the hope of Wonder Woman but
when it comes to the character of ma and
PAW Kent and Lana Lang they hold a very
particular place in DC Comics not just
with Superman but with DC Comics as a
whole and what I mean by that is that is
that Jonathan and Martha can kind of
represent the greater wisdom the people
who kind of impose these Pearls of
Wisdom on us that was the nature of ma
of Jonathan and Martha Kim helping
Superman become more than just a guy
with powers and become something that
represented Hope For Humanity Lana Lang
plays a very important role because she
was the first person to recognize or to
learn the powers of Superman and taught
him how to use them so she was very much
kind of like a younger guiding hand for
Clark Kent as opposed to the the Pearls
of Wisdom that were instilled on him by
Jonathan and Martha Kent but with the
nature of sanctuary itself what it does
is it basically changes your environment
using Kryptonian crystals and it allows
you to use whatever you need to do in
order to get past things for Booster
Gold he's facing himself that booster
himself has a lot of unresolved issues
here now these aren't really delved into
too far in this you know it's just kind
of like hey basically everything you do
screws up why well because you're not
doing it for good reasons you're doing
it because you're trying to prove that
you're an actual hero and that's the
nature of booster and those are the two
diet those two diametrically opposing
views that his character represents on
one half you have Booster Gold who wants
to be the hero and on the other half you
have Booster Gold doing everything to
show he's a hero when in reality he's
not he's a con man he doesn't think like
a good guy he thinks like how can I
prove that I'm a hero by doing this he's
basically trying to fix what's not
broken and so what that does is it
creates all kinds of problems for his
character now before any of this goes on
before we really get any HBO huge
explanation on what's happening with
these guys suddenly alarms start going
off and when they do Lagoon voice killed
he's one of the people that's killed
Wally races out only to find that of
course red arrow Arsenal whatever you
want to call him Roy Harper is basically
dead and the person overlooking it all
is Harley Quinn and Harley Quinn cracks
Wally West over the head with a with a
mallet and kills Wally West and so is
this kind of like okay well then Harley
Quinn of course you know was one who
killed Wally presumably is the one who
seems to have killed everybody else it's
kind of intriguing and it's kind of
interesting because we don't really know
exactly what direction things are going
and it's one of these scenarios where
it's kind of like vantage point right
like all these things are happening but
we're looking at it from different
perspectives trying to figure out who
who's ultimately responsible for the
death of all these characters
okay so picking up with heroes in crisis
part four God we're kind of behind uh we
need to get caught up like I let
everybody in the comic book YouTube
scene get ahead of me
now I have to crush them all with my
uploads okay so getting into heroes in
crisis part four so this is all right
this is kind of cool because one of the
things you bear in mind again kind of
getting back into this this year is a
crisis thing this is designed to show
the side of the superheroes that we
don't see right so like it's really
familiar it's really similar to like
Civil War I mean for those of you guys
who never read Marvel Civil War of
course it was a big Calamity the
Superheroes versus superheroes but what
made it cool was you saw like small
little moments where there were
different Heroes like t-re who were like
I cannot afford to be a college kid and
a superhero at the same time with my
identity out there in the world and if I
have to choose one I'll choose to go to
college and so like they would quit and
so it was like these small little things
and that's what's cool about heroes in
crisis initially this picks up with like
Tempest who's basically drunk in a bar
and just kind of rambling on and going
on about nonsense it's not designed to
really say like he's he's endured like a
huge shock or anything like that it's
designed to show these Heroes at their
worst when they're at their lowest
points because what this is designed to
do what the whole content of Huron
crisis is designed to do is to humanize
the heroes even more than they already
are and to basically say like whenever
you go and buy a Batman book all you see
is Batman fighting one villain after
another but what happens between the
panels like what happens between these
issues what's Tempest doing what's
Superman doing what's Batman doing what
are they doing between these conflicts
how are they coping with like all these
major events that are going on and so on
and so forth that's what it's designed
to focus on and that's why it's so cool
because what we end up doing here is we
switch over to Booster Gold now remember
Booster Gold was the person who is
basically on the scene when like the
whole event of really like the death of
all these superheroes went on during
Sanctuary you know he woke up Harley
Quinn was there but as far as
everybody's aware they believe that
Booster Gold was the one to do it and so
what he ends up doing is basically
taking this kind of lasso test where one
woman puts the lasso around his hands
and where he basically divulges
everything he saw and what he says
really kind of it's really cool for Tom
King to do this because it kind of
Catches Us up but what he says is
basically like I was there I made a
confession just like everybody else and
then like all hell broke Clues and
that's basically it like as far as I
know Harley Quinn was the one who did it
because like I came out there and like
everybody was dead Harley Quinn had this
bleeding Mallet and then she started
hitting me with it and then I woke up
later on and that's it that's all he
really knows I mean that's one of the
things to bear in mind is that when it
comes to Booster Gold he's kind of the
perfect culprit to blame if you're the
person who committed all these acts
because remember booster's entire
superhero Antics are shrouded in fraud
he's a guy from the future who who
dreamed of being a superhero after
beating being basically a nobody he
stole a whole bunch of Technology from a
museum he traveled back to the present
day and said I'm a hero from the future
once that was found out he was just kind
of like okay whatever this guy's not
really much of a hero at all but he
still kind of went along and did various
hero Antics but he's really just kind of
like the Class Clown the goofball the
one who's more inclined to screw things
up than to get things right and so if
you're a person who's going to commit a
crime no one sees what it is that you've
done and Booster Gold happens to be
there he's the perfect guy to blame and
so this is when the plot thickens
because what we do here is we switch
over to to Lois Lane speaking with
Superman you know talking to Clark Kent
and what she basically reveals here is
that she's been getting information
she's basically getting the video files
these confessions that people have been
making they've been sent directly to her
now she of course is kind of operating
under the assumption that if they've
been sent to her they've been sent to
other people but remember Lois Lane is a
reporter and so for her it's the story
that really seems to count and that's
one of the kind of things that Tom King
really draws here is he almost kind of
draws this idea that for Lois Lane it's
the story first and then everything else
second but it's not necessarily that way
because the case she makes here is
someone's gonna drop this scoop my
source gave me these files the
implication seems to be that somebody
else or other people have the files or
or could get the files besides her
Source or at the very least her Source
got the files in such a way to where
they could be leaked to the public and
so her idea is we have to make this
story public and we have to make it fast
because if we don't somebody else will
do it before I do and they won't be
unbiased they'll put a slant on it and
it'll be things like our superheroes
trustworthy are superheroes good guys
you know they'll do it in such a way to
where it has a political leaning where I
is Lois Lane can do it in the most
non-splant way possible and so that's
why it's one of the cool things that
kind of goes on here is because it's the
question of does Lois Lane have a moral
obligation to publish the story given
its very nature and the fact that if
somebody else does it they'll do it in
Wikipedia could be a negative way it's
possible they could do it in a positive
way but remember when it comes to the
superheroes and and DC Comics there's a
lot of negative slant towards them
they're not inherently bad and it's not
like society as a whole views them as a
negative but it's one of these things
where the news exists to sell itself and
so if the news can be sold in such a way
to where it can be done in a negative
fashion and people will eat it up more
likely than they would be if it were
done in a positive fashion then that's
what they will do and so again it's It's
Kind of a Funny scenario because then
what you end up doing is picking up with
bad girl and Harley Quinn and the two of
them literally just start immediately
coming to blows now there's a couple
reasons for this one because it's Harley
Quinn and Batgirl and two because Harley
Quinn's basically on the run here that
seems to be the indication throughout
this whole story and she's essentially
like fleeing for her life because for
those who have been investigating this
whole thing and those who are looking
past Booster Gold is the immediate
suspect that makes Harley Quinn Public
Enemy Number One it makes her the number
one suspect so she was quite literally
caught with blood on her hands with the
whole thing that was going on in
sanctuary and so with Batgirl showing up
you're of course the kind of discussion
is looking I'm not really here to bust
you or anything like I'm here to help
you I'm here to try to figure out what's
going on so on and so forth and so the
two of them kind of kind of calm down
out and sort of hug and then throw from
there but it's kind of interesting here
because what this ends up doing is is
sort of switching over to Blue Beetle
and this is kind of a cool little thing
here because remember Blue Beetle and
Booster Gold there are two peas in a pod
they're the best of friends and one of
the things that really gets talked about
here with Blue Beetle is is that exact
thing when Ted cord is going through
here and he's talking about these
different concepts one of the things
that he hits on is his friendship with
Booster Gold and that's why he says like
I put Booster Gold first like I trust
Booster Gold if he says he didn't do it
then I believe him but it's a very
important thing here because as he goes
through and kind of talks he talks about
the nature of what it means to be a hero
right like you're effectively surrounded
by death and suffering all the time
that's the nature of what it means to be
a superhero is that Heroes you know
various Heroes die all the time and
that's why this story is so cool is
because DC Comics on the whole largely
focuses on like the popular Heroes the
cool kids table that's basically DC you
don't really see what goes on in like
the Band Geek table or like the comic
book nerd table you don't really see
what goes on on those little tables over
there but we're kind of left to assume
that they're Heroes they do things and
some stuff happens and they sort of go
about their business and they go to bed
and all that kind of good stuff but you
don't really hear their story you don't
see which of which one of them die you
don't see which one of them lose friends
you never really learn about that with
Blue Beetle here he's kind of like that
happens all the time like in that table
over there they lost four or five guys
in the last three weeks you look at that
table over there well they've lost 10
guys in the last year but you never hear
that story but when he says he's a
superhero he's sitting at the tables
just like everybody else surrounded by
all these different tables of all these
different Heroes some come and some go
and it's just the nature of the Beast
and it's kind of like how do you get
past that how do you learn to cope with
it and the response he gives is it's
just the way it goes it's just kind of
it's just the nature of the Beast how
this whole thing happens that's why he
says when things get hard and things get
tough Booster Gold is the one that he
goes to and that's why it's kind of cool
because for all the benefit that cord
industries does in terms of providing a
kind of financial back end to the
building of sanctuary to a lot of the
different things that go on at the end
of the day Booster Gold and and really
Blue Beetle are still kind of considered
to be outliers they're Heroes but
they're not really Heroes you know what
I mean like they're not really part of
the Justice League like they're there
but when people say oh my God we got to
get a hold of the Justice League nobody
thinks a Blue Beetle nobody thinks a
Booster Gold they're just kind of Heroes
who were there and like they serve a
purpose occasionally even in the real
world reading comic books it's kind of
an on running joke the most significant
moment in Ted Court's life was getting
shot in the head like I mean it's just
one of those things that you kind of get
when when it comes to Comics it's just
the guys who are down there and so
that's why things get sort of crazy is
because what happens here is we
basically pick up with Superman when
he's speaking directly with Batman and
Wonder Woman now remember they're the
ones who made Sanctuary right like
Sanctuary uses the technology of
Superman in terms of you know the the
available Technologies and the Fortress
of Solitude that can create like
Holograms Illusions different things
like that so it uses that technology
with regards to creating like Holograms
and so on coping mechanisms different
things like that it uses the Ingenuity
and the money of Batman in terms of how
to pull it all together and of course
it's all based on the empathy of Wonder
Woman and her ability to like understand
other people's pain so between the
Trinity they effectively built sanctuary
and so it makes sense that with things
popping off the three of them are
talking but Superman shows up here and
says look there's something that I have
to make you guys aware of and when the
question is what you know the response
is Lois Lane is going to go live with
the story about saying Sanctuary she has
all the the various data logs now of
course Batman's response is that's not
possible they should all be gone and
deleted and remember that makes sense
because what you're talking about here
are confessions of superheroes and no
one knows what they're gonna say when
Wonder Woman did her confession she
talked about killing Maxwell Lord when
Superman did his confession he talked
about dying when Batman had his
confession he talked about having his
back broken by Bane these are the
innermost thoughts of people at of
various superheroes being recorded on
these data logs things they would never
share with the world things they don't
want anybody else to know their deepest
darkest desires their deepest darkest
confessions all are being made on these
data log tapes and that's why they're
supposed to be deleted almost right off
the bat so that nobody can ever get
their hands on them but what seems to
have happened here is by one means or
another someone got their hands on all
these different video tapes and when the
questions asked when is Lois going live
with the story Superman says well that's
why I'm telling you it went live 33
seconds ago and so it's just like wow so
so basically like all this information
is now out there about the superhero
Community all these confessions are now
out there it's literally throwing
everything out there in into the world
and taking all the deepest darkest
Secrets especially with Batman when
Batman's status is like I've had a
desire to kill Heroes before like I've
had a desire to eliminate them to
destroy them to wipe them off the face
of the Earth but I can't do that because
it goes against everything I stand for
like with those confessions being being
made and thrown out there they're
available for the world to see which is
going to fundamentally change how the
World Views superheroes
okay so continuing on with heroes in
crisis part five this really deals more
with like the aftermath and it's almost
kind of like Superman's appeal to
humanity now there are a couple things
that go on here but again there's only
really like two big takeaways from all
this there's only really like like two
big moments from from this whole thing
but I like the way that this is done
because I feel like Tom King uses the
nature of Superman so exceedingly well
so when it comes to Superman and DC
Comics this is a very important thing to
remember here Superman is a contextual
character and what that means is that
people's enjoyment of Superman comics is
relative to how he's written and while
you would normally say that about a
bunch of other Heroes for the most part
you can really get away with a lot of
things with a lot of different Heroes
with Batman you can tell really dark and
gritty stories like Batman in game and
you can even go back to Steve ingleheart
where the Joker was like dark and
comedic and you can go into those those
different aspects Teen Titans you can do
a lot of teenage drama or you could do
happier stories there's a lot of of
Shifting around that goes there but for
Superman he's not really that flexible
and the reason why is because of how
long he's been around and what he stands
for Mark Wade did this really really
good interview years ago it was this was
probably I don't know maybe 10 years ago
and what he said was the reason why
Superman is so popular why he stands the
test of time is because he's everything
to everyone like every generation
Superman is whatever that generation
needs him to be so like during the 60s
when it was all anti-vietnam war and the
hippie movement was that it's at the
height of its popularity Superman was
kind of a reflection of that he was
anti-war it was it was always that way
it's always been that way with his
character that's kind of how he
maintains his relevance and so one of
the worst things you can do with
Superman is try to kind of like force
him into a role that's just not very
appealing that's not really in the
nature of his character but Tom King
does that exceedingly well and so one of
the funny things about this is that it
initially picks up with like the really
kind of the aftermath of this article
published by Lois Lane being sent out to
the world basically showing like all
these Revelations and all these
statements and all these Admissions and
different things like that they were all
brought to bear by the various
superheroes who were out there making
their admissions within the confines of
sanctuary and so in response to the
Superman immediately addresses the crowd
and there's a reason why it's super
Superman the in-universe landscape in DC
Comics is Superman's the most respected
superhero on the planet right like his
word is beyond contestation that's the
nature of his character that's the
nature of how he functions within you
know on Earth within DC Comics is this
like the one guy you don't question and
it's the one hero that like everyone has
respect for the villains respect him the
heroes respect him even if they don't
like him even if they fight him all the
time they still respect him and so it
makes sense to parade him out and be the
one that basically says things because
for the most part when you're Superman
shy of somebody running up on you with
Kryptonite or like Doomsday not many
people out there are going to be able to
like challenge I mean the number of
people who can legitimately challenge
Superman on Earth you can probably count
on one hand and so with that being the
case it's not really like Superman is
much of a challenge and so there's not
really a whole lot for him to lose and
so he's just kind of out there talking
to everybody and what he basically says
is that he's prepared a statement for
this whole thing and what he essentially
says here is that like the basis behind
Sanctuary is that one he acknowledges
there was an incident that a bunch of
metahumans were killed and that the
prime suspects here are Harley Quinn and
Booster Gold of course if you guys are
curious about that feel free free to
watch the previous videos but in
response to this what he basically does
you know why you have like Booster Gold
and Blue Beetle essentially like
investigating the whole crime scene
which we'll talk more about that here in
a minute Superman kind of makes this
statement and basically says the whole
basis behind Sanctuary was that it was
supposed to be a place where Heroes can
go to essentially recoup from all the
things they've experienced and is
basically Superman saying like these are
just people and that's kind of the cool
thing about it is because from from the
way that comic books are traditionally
written and the way the superheroes are
traditionally done they almost seem like
gods among men and for the average
person walking around it'd be different
it'd be difficult to differentiate
between the two and it's kind of the
funny thing because even Batman made
that case and the story that Tom King
wrote where you had Batman serving jury
duty and he was questioned you know
Bruce Wayne was questioning the nature
of the Batman concept and said that
people call Batman God because Batman
saves them where God does not and so if
that's the case then they have to
consider Batman God because if that's
not true then how do you justify a man
that saves him it was this really cool
introspective look at the character but
on the whole across the board it's
usually been done in such a way that the
various superheroes save the world from
multiple threats and Humanity whether
they want to admit it or not looks to
those superheroes to save them and
oftentimes forgets the idea that they
are just people that more often than not
with the exception of Superman Martian
Manhunter maybe one or two other people
that they were born on Earth and they
were they were born to parents and their
parents raised them to become productive
members of society and they're just
trying to make their way in the world as
best as they possibly can and people
forget that people look at that and they
just say like you're a superhero your
job is to save me and if you don't save
me it means you didn't do your job and
the idea behind this is to say like it
was a place of recovery it was a place
of respite it was a place of the for
these people for these Heroes to go and
to basically recover from the various
experiences they've had because they
can't bring that to your attention and
they can't bring that to your attention
because that shows weakness Superman
can't get up there and basically start
crying and showing all manner because
people will lose faith in him if you
show people that God can bleed they will
lose faith in him like that's that's the
idea behind it is it like if Superman or
one of these meta humans got out there
started crying or started showing
vulnerability or emotion that ultimately
people would begin to to lose faith in
them well if they're this weak of a
person how can we rely on them to save
us how can we rely on them to be there
when the times are the absolute toughest
and so with that being the case they
needed a private place where they could
go to they could spill their darkest
Secrets they could tell everything that
they ever wanted to get off their chest
and it would immediately be deleted it
would immediately be removed and that
would never really be the case anymore
it's kind of an interesting thing
because Superman even asked that
question he says if this was a place
that people went to if this is a place
that they went to in order to find some
measure of respite some measure of
Solace does that mean that they are now
unworthy because of the fact that they
are human they do need to find some way
to let all this steam off because
they're not Gods walking on Earth
they're just people who happen to have
fantastic powers does that somehow make
them unworthy does it make them people
who are are somehow not capable of being
effective you know not only that and
because of the fact that it brings them
back down to base level and because of
the fact that it returned them to being
perceived as humans in the mind of
humanity well humans are fallible humans
screw up humans do stupid things people
say and do things all the time that they
would normally never say under any
normal circumstance but in the height of
emotion suddenly logic goes right out
the window and when that's the case how
do you in turn justify that when you've
got someone like Superman what happens
if Lois Lane dies and Superman has an
emotional crisis well then you run into
Injustice and so that's that's the kind
of scenario that's being presented here
is what happens when those who were
deemed as infallible with the power of
God suddenly become fallible and
emotional well then suddenly the world
could be turned upside down the world
could just be left in a total state of
catastrophe and that's the whole point
of Superman's making here and that's why
it works so well is because he basically
says these are people from different
countries different walks of life that
I've watched day in and day out face off
against threats that most of you guys
couldn't even imagine let alone see I've
seen them achieve an insurmountable
things I've seen them do things that are
that are astronomical I've seen men and
women who can tap into nature itself
I've seen those who can use the power of
animals I've seen Gods who ascend from
the oceans in order to try to make peace
with the surface world and literally try
to bridge the gap between these two
things I've met aliens from outer space
I've met other kryptonians where I
thought I was alone I've met all these
different people who come from all these
different facets of what you would call
a superhero Community but at the end of
the day they're still just people they
know fear they know love they know hate
they know all these emotions and because
they know all these things it's easy to
be overcome by them and that's why it's
so intriguing and that's why it's so
fascinating because he says that was the
basis behind Sanctuary it wasn't to
manipulate me it wasn't to lie it wasn't
a trick it wasn't to be a place where
they could basically say like I killed a
person and I'm essentially performing
the same act as like you know confessing
to a priest and now it can't be used
against me that's not the basis behind
it it's a place for those individuals
who have powers but are effectively
human to basically deal with the various
torments and Nightmares they've endured
over the course of their entire
experience in the superhero landscape
and so that's that's so awesome because
what it does is again it kind of
humanizes all these different
superheroes and I've seen a few
complaints here and there it's like oh
well you know here goes DC humanizing
heroes again well I mean yeah it kind of
makes sense to me unless you're saying
Batman's not human so again it's sort of
an interesting concept here to basically
see that kind of worked in and and to
kind of bring them back down because to
me I liked Heroes who were relatable
like unlike Heroes who were interesting
I mean for all the complaints people
will make about DC saying well here they
go making Heroes relatable again there's
an awful lot of arguments about how
Superman sucks because he's not
relatable so I I like all these
different points that are kind of being
made here and it's really really
interesting but one of the big points
that's also kind of made is that Booster
Gold basically says because he's a hero
who's so well versed in time travel he
understands the basis behind the rules
of time travel right like in DC Comics
you have a kind of set of guidelines
right like you have the temporal
Authority whatever it is like basically
a police force that makes sure that a
person from the future doesn't get time
travel technology and then starts
screwing up the past and totally
destroying the time stream and so one of
the things Booster Gold says is that in
order to verify how far back a person's
gone in order to see whether or not a
person is actually time travel when they
weren't supposed to what they would do
is they would take your RNA and they
would compare it to your birthday and if
your RNA was off if your RNA was not 34
years old and you're actually 34 years
old that's how they would know and boost
their goal basically being kind of a
shady guy his had to essentially
understand this concept in order to find
ways to work around it and so when he
and Blue Beetle were like investigating
all these different things what they
basically discovered here is that the
body of of Wally West is essentially
five days old this something's not right
that there's something going on in this
bigger picture things aren't really what
they seem to be now Tom King makes this
exceedingly vague he makes this
incredibly vague and he does that
intentionally because we don't really
know how this is going to go we don't
really know where this Rabbit Hole leads
to but it's really intriguing and it's
actually really cool because it's one of
these things where like it's effectively
Tom King saying not everything is what
it seems to be not everything is what it
appears to be and again like as The
Story Goes On we'll essentially begin to
learn more
okay so picking up with heroes in crisis
part six like a lot of this a lot of the
stories that we've seen so far it's kind
of split into sections and so we're
gonna kind of take each one of these
because what it does is actually sort of
bounces back and forth between a guy
named narc and then Harley Quinn and
then Wally West so we're gonna kind of
take these in segments but with Harley
Quinn like like hers is really the most
straightforward because what's ironic
about this is that with Sanctuary poison
ivy had shown up here presumably for the
sake of like getting help but for the
most part poison ivy is just kind of
like I'm fine the way I am this is
really more for Harley Quinn so it's
really more that like she snuck Harley
Quinn in there which is kind of a bad
guy doing what a bad guy does I guess
but the gist behind this really seems to
be more towards kind of leaning towards
the idea that they're really kind of
appear to be some criminals out there
who are just incorrigible and that the
indication seems to be that Harley Quinn
was perceived as being one of those
criminals that there was really no way
to help her there was no way to make her
better but the cool thing about this is
that Han King kind of hits on the idea
that she's not that far gone what she
needed was the right kind of treatment
and the way this seems to kind of come
about is when poison ivy starts helping
Harley Quinn by basically creating like
these manifestations of of the Joker and
what they do is go through and
essentially like torment The Joker and
kill him destroy him that kind of
different thing because that's what the
Joker did to Harley Quinn and that's one
of the things to bear in mind here is
that a lot of those themes that weren't
necessarily hit on you know that were
really hidden on the nose and Batman the
Animated Series certainly were in the
comics that the Joker was exceedingly
abusive but Harley Quinn kept coming
back due to some warped perspective of
what love is supposed to be now how you
know how Harley Quinn got to that point
is really kind of reflective of whatever
her origin story is right I mean she's
got one origin story in Batman the
Animated Series she's got another origin
story in the actual DC Comics and then
she's got another origin story when she
was rebooted in the new 52 but
throughout all of those the common
themes are basically that Harley Quinn
in some form or fashion was kind of
brought up with with a victim's
mentality with kind of like an abusive
mentality so it's kind of strange the
way it all plays out but again it sort
of makes sense with her character in
terms of how she's progressed so far so
like literally poison ivy is using her
her Vines to like kill the Joker like
the Joker's like killing himself
basically like cutting his own throat
it's basically using these things as a
means to kind of help Harley get past
the kind of pain that she's experienced
and stop seeing the joker as someone
that could legitimately torment her and
see the joker as somebody who's just
easily killed because in a lot of ways
The Joker Is The Joker is really like an
easily killable guy the story of Harley
Quinn kind of ends when the alarm Bells
go off basically saying like you know
there's an emergency you guys all need
to make their way to the exit because
Harley's not supposed to be there poison
ivy tells her stay here I'm gonna go see
what's going on and then of course as we
know poison ivy dies and so what we end
up doing at this point is we switch over
to to Wally West now for Wally West it's
kind of interesting here because the big
torment of Wally isn't necessarily like
any sort of scenario he's been put
through as a hero with regards to like a
villain he face and took like an
emotional toll or anything like that
it's being cut off from the world like
that's the torment of Wally West that
when everything happened with Flashpoint
and the characters were effectively
rebooted Wally West was stuck in the
speed force so when Barry Allen came out
when the whole reboot finished Barry
Allen had like his whole life and he was
so sure of the life he lived being the
right one with like Donna Troy and Dick
Grayson and all those characters living
their lives they've effectively lived
their lives the way they're supposed to
Wally West is suddenly being thrown in
here and because of the fact that like
this this huge event of Flashpoint
happened and and nobody remembers what
happened before the events of Flashpoint
Wally's mindset being he's one of the
few who does remember is like things
aren't the way they're supposed to be he
does he's not married to his wife he's
not married to Linda Park he can't find
giant Iris as kids so in his mind like
the world's literally in shambles and
for a brief moment when Barry Allen
basically realized who he was and Barry
Allen brought him back it was kind of
like hey like everything's gonna go back
to the way it was supposed to only for
us to find out that it's not now it's
kind of interesting that the way Tom
King does this because in reality Tom
King doesn't really do anything to
change the nature of Wally West what he
does is he uses the story to frame the
perspective of Wally West in a slightly
different way that it really is just
kind of a crushing situation that
there's no going back that that's kind
of the fear and really the basis behind
Wally West's life right now he can't go
back to the way things used to be and
that's kind of the cool thing about the
the heroes in crisis story and the
nature of Wally is because when Superman
Embraces him and says hey man like
you're back and when Nightwing Embraces
him and Donna Troy Embraces him and and
Roy Harper Embraces and they keep saying
like you're Batman you're the embodiment
of Hope but the question that Wally has
is how could I be the embodiment of Hope
if I'm hopeless and that's kind of
that's kind of the cool scenario here is
things change the world moves forward
you've got to change with the times and
so it's kind of a cool little thing
because when of course all that begins
to go down when all that begins to
happen basically like Wally despite
despite the fact that he's he's
basically surrounded by the Titans
despite the fact that Superman knows who
he is because Superman knows how things
were before the events of Flashpoint
despite the fact that he's surrounded by
like Barry Allen Iris West these people
that essentially know who he is it
doesn't change the fact that Wally West
in his entirety feels completely alone
he feels completely alone and cut off
because from his perspective he's in a
world that he doesn't belong in and so
that's what makes it kind of crazy is so
again it's really interesting because
again like the alarm Bells go off and
then it all kind of comes to a head now
again we'll get to that point here in a
second in terms of what comes next but
at this point we jump back to a
character named narc now narc was a
character who originally appeared back
in 1971 by Steve Skeets I think it was
like the guy who created him uh but
essentially he's like an old school
pre-crisis character but essentially
like this version of his character is
kind of reminiscing on how things were
back in the in the early days of his
life and in the early days of narc's
life he was just like a neanderthal
right like he was a caveman essentially
and what had happened was that a
meteorite had struck the Earth and then
a fraction of that meteorite some of the
crystal composed inside bonded itself to
him and basically like jump started his
and his intellect made him super smart
when that happened of course eventually
he was frozen in ice and then basically
he was stuck there for like hundreds and
thousands of of years until he was
eventually discovered by like the Teen
Titans being discovered by the Teen
Titans he was essentially let loose and
then like kind of joined the team for a
little while and then his fate was never
really specified now in the new 52 we
ended up learning like that there was
like a new version of him but again none
of that really ties into like how his
character quote unquote died according
to Lilith in the uh in the pre-flash
point landscape but again at this moment
right now because of the fact that he's
so intelligent he reminisces on
characters like Hobbes and uh and
Rousseau now Hobbes is a is basically
talking about Thomas Hobbs and Thomas
Hobbs was his philosopher that had this
really really dark perspective right
like he he considered the nature of
humanity to be a perpetual and permanent
war of all against all you had something
called a state of nature there was no
ordered government it was just kind of
humans really more of like what passes
for nomadic tribes just kind of making
their way but it's essentially a state
of nature no order government of any
kind Thomas Hobbes believed that because
resources are finite that resources
basically have to be preserved but the
only way to really preserve those
resources is to create what was called
the Leviathan which is essentially like
in order government created by whatever
Society exists at the time and so again
like there are a lot of other themes
that go into it in terms of like abuses
of power if a king abuses his powers
it's just the way it goes there's really
not a whole lot you can do about that I
mean you could try to overthrow the king
but a new one will take his place and
then he may be just abusive as well it's
the price you pay to maintain some kind
of like order and structure in society
that you can't have at all but again
Thomas Hobbes was very dark and and very
very Bleak but at the same time when
narc is kind of talking about his life
he says there was a lot of freedom back
then like in the early days of his life
there was a lot of freedom that a man
really just kind of lived by the sweat
of his brow that's all it was you know
that he basically he fought with nature
in order to kind of maintain his role
among nature itself you know and that's
when he kind of begins to go into
Jean-Jacques Rousseau and Jean-Jacques
Rousseau is a philosopher who can
compared the modern day to the the state
of nature and basically said state of
nature was better because people had
actual Freedom that there really is no
Freedom right now there's freedom in so
far as your ability to make decisions
but your ability to make decisions is
predicated based on like societal
structures right so like I'm going to
Tweet but I have to make sure I don't
tweet the wrong thing otherwise I could
lose my job 10 years later I mean it's
it's that kind of it's not really
Freedom per se you can't say anything
you want to you can't do anything you
want to you're limited by like the rules
of society by the scope of the society
that you live in and that's really kind
of what it what what Mark hits at is he
had absolute freedom back then that the
only real rules of society the only real
rules of the world he lived in was
survival of the fittest that he needs to
eat but another Neanderthal needs to eat
and so where he tracks down the kill
another Neanderthal will run up on him
and try to take it and basically
whoever's the strongest kills the other
and then gets to Feast on the on the on
the animal they killed that was the rule
of nature it was the the law of the land
those who were strong enough to survive
are the only ones who deserve to survive
so again it was it's it's a little bit
darker but again like there's a lot of
lot of themes of Freedom that go in
there and it's kind of interesting when
you look at it that way because narc
kind of has a point that like back in
his early days it really was just
Freedom he was free to do whatever he
wanted to to live his life however he
wanted to there were no bounds there
there were no limits there the only
limits imposed on him were the physical
limits of his body at that point in time
the limits of where he could travel in
terms of what's too cold what's too hot
and the limits in terms of what his mind
could comprehend and that was it
everything else he could do whatever he
wanted to and imagine that kind of
Freedom imagine the freedom to go where
you want when you want how you want to
say anything you want to like imagine
that kind of freedom and then compare
that to the modern day and look how free
you really not that was kind of the
argument of Jean-Jacques Rousseau you're
not really as free as you believe you're
as free as you've been told and so it's
it's really kind of a cool comparison
between these these two different
philosophies but again like you know the
alarm Bells go off Mark ends up making
his way off and basically says hey look
maybe I'm kind of overthinking it all
but at the same time like that's when
everything kind of begins to unfold
again when like all these different
superheroes end up getting killed on the
grounds of sanctuary and so that's what
we basically end up finding out Booster
Gold was the one who killed Wally West
and presumably Booster Gold was the one
who killed everybody else that seems to
be the case here as well it's kind of
interesting because what is what it sort
of hits at is that when Harley Quinn had
shown up there with a blood splattered
Mallet that Mallet was actually her like
smashing the Joker at least it seems to
be that she was killing the various
duplicates of the Joker that were being
made in sanctuary as a way to basically
heal her wounds she wasn't actually
going through and killing superheroes
the actual killer here seems to be
Booster Gold so again it's pretty
interesting and it's really I really
like the direction that it's taking in
terms of how the story is unfolding
okay so we're getting back into heroes
in crisis in part seven and this is one
of the things that I love a lot about
the heroes in crisis story is it's more
of like a philosophical story right and
and for some people that doesn't really
do it for right like for some people
they like action-packed stories like
fighting and and the traditional comic
book story kind of kind of Tale But the
way that this is done by Tom King it's
really more of like a philosophical look
at Heroes right like it kind of removes
the action to a degree I mean it has
some in there but it's more of just the
philosophical look at things and a lot
of this really this the like the biggest
part of the story focuses on Wally West
because in reality like Wally West is
the character that I think a lot of
people are that were at least at the
outset of DC rebirth the most intrigued
in and even during the events of New 52
right like Flashpoint happen New 52
kicked off and then Barry Allen was I'm
sorry Wally West was nowhere to be found
and everybody wanted to know where like
classic Wally West went we got a
rebooted version of his character but
some fans reject that other fans
embraced it and the result was that on
the whole people were just curious where
the red-haired Wally West went so when
he came back then it was suddenly like
okay well then how do we make this work
and that's really been like the whole
nature of his character and even up
until now even through like Joshua
Williamson's Flash run all the way up
until now this really kind of seems to
be the point where it focuses the most
on like the experience of Wally after
essentially having come back now there
are a couple things that go on in here
there is Booster Gold there is Harley
it's not really essential I don't think
it may be that later on it is and if it
is then we'll kind of come back to it
but for the most part a lot of this
focuses on Batman Barry Allen and then
of course Wally West and initially this
kind of picks up with like Wally West's
introduction into Sanctuary the idea
that he's really kind of hopeful here
and that's the cool thing about this is
that you can sort of see this transition
as The Story Goes On you see this kind
of transition from with Wally West where
he's initially very hopeful and he's
very optimistic in terms of the purpose
of sanctuary can serve right because the
idea of sanctuary was was supposed to be
a place of respite a place where like
people could go where characters could
go and kind of spill their deepest
darkest Secrets or in some form or
fashion offer a revelation or at the
very least cope with the things that
cause them harm in order to find some
measure of Peace but it's basically
Wally just kind of coming coming to
terms with the fact that he's he's here
and he's sort of celebrating the fact
that he can kind of move past all all
the struggle and strife that he's
endured again we'll talk about that here
in a second but one of the cool things
about this is that what it does it kind
of transitions over to Barry Allen and
Batman now remember when it comes to
Batman and Barry Allen Barry Allen is
really kind of on a Warpath because of
the fact that Wally West died that's
really kind of why he's playing the role
that he is and heroes in crisis that you
literally had Booster Gold who showed up
and kind of spilled the beans that Wally
West died and then Barry just kind of
lost his mind right and then of course
Batman's investigating because it's
Batman and so from here it jumps back
into Wally West again now with Wally
West the cool thing here is that as he
starts to go through this he starts
talking about progress and he starts
talking about all these things that are
important to him Linda Iris Jai all
these individuals but the problem is
that they're all gone and as you look
through this you kind of notice like
this this difference this this kind of
shift it's not a huge shift but it's
kind of shift he's not as optimistic
anymore he's not as hopeful anymore it's
only his second week but he's not as
hopeful anymore as time passes he seems
to lose more and more hope but the whole
basis behind this is the fact that
everything he knows is gone right like
that's the whole thing behind Walling
imagine for example that like you woke
up tomorrow and like none of your family
knew who you were everything you know
everything of value to you has vanished
no one knows who you are now that's the
that's the issue that Wally West is in
now conventional wisdom would say well
then just tell them just walk up there
and just tell them but how do you tell
them that how do you walk up to a person
who as far as they're aware has never
met you has no idea who you are and say
we had a family together they're gonna
think you're crazy not only that from
the perspective of Wally West one of the
things to bear in mind is he's a tried
and true hero and so when that's the
case he kind of has to ask himself the
question is it really better off for
Linda Park to know the history between
herself and Wally there's no guarantee
that she'll do the same thing Iris West
did when when Barry basically revealed
everything to Iris and said hey we were
supposed to be together and and when
basically Iris learned everything about
Wally that hey like I'm your long-lost
nephew or and basically like I've been
stuck in the speed force and all that
there's no guarantee that Linda would
react the same way as Iris where Iris
embraced Wally Linda could rebuke him
would Wally be able to withstand that
and would it be better off for Linda or
is it better to just kind of leave her
be and so from here again it kind of
shifts back to Batman and to Barry and
they're literally running through like
all the safe houses that that Booster
Gold and that Ted cord Blue Beetle
usually stay at and it's kind of a funny
little exchange here like Batman's like
hey man you could just use the bad radio
like instead of like running all over
the place and then running back every
time he visits somewhere run to
Australia run back run to Berlin run
back you can just use the bat radio and
tell me you don't haven't found anything
and Barry's like yeah but like I'm
faster than the bat radio and Batman's
like well I mean I mean I'm not so sure
about that but I guess if it's done to
the right frequencies I could be wrong
for the first time that I'm aware of in
DC Comics Batman admits that he could be
wrong but you know kind of going into
Wally West getting into a second week
here this is really really cool because
what it does is it kind of refreshes you
know uh I guess really Wally's kind of
origin story it's basically explaining
everything about his life and it's kind
of like hey look I was a hero since I
was a teenager I modeled myself after
Barry Allen Barry Allen died and I
became the new Flash but the cool thing
about this is Tom King kind of relies on
us as the reader to sort of know these
little these little tidbits of what kind
of goes on behind the scenes right like
you had Barry Allen as as the flash you
ran all the way up until crisis on
infinite Earth and Wally West was Kid
Flash and then Barry Allen died during
cries on infiniters or at least he was
believed he died and then during the
events of final crisis it was revealed
that he was stuck in the speed force but
for all intents and purposes post-crisis
Barry was dead and so during that time
Wally West stepped into the role of
becoming the new Flash and in the early
stories under Mike Barron it was all
about Wally West basically being under
the shadow of Barry can he ever truly be
as good as Barry could he ever really be
the great kind of flash superhero that
Barry Allen was constantly comparing
himself to Barry Allen it wasn't until
Mike Baron left the title and Mark Wade
took over that suddenly it turned into
okay let's start focusing on the
expansion of Wally it was a natural
progression once Wally had kind of
stepped into his role as being the flash
accepted his role as a hero then we
started getting stories like terminal
velocity we started getting stories like
the return of Barry Allen which was the
basically post-crisis origin for eobard
Thon the reverse flash we started
getting like all these different these
different expansions on the nature of
Wally and then him growing I guess him
kind of moving on further marrying Linda
Park who I think was a reporter at the
time eventually having giant Iris you
know being involved in Infinite Crisis
as Barry Allen actually coming back you
know during like the the original flash
rebirth event it's kind of cool with all
these little things but Tom King kind of
relies on us that's one of the reasons
why it's sort of a a little bit of a
goodie here is because for somebody
who's new is okay cool it's him doing
his origin for those who have been part
of the flash Mythos for a long time they
can kind of look at this and say okay I
understand where he's coming from
because like here are all the things
that Wally West has been through over
the course of his life as a hero and
that's why it's interesting because what
this does is it kind of really allows us
to sort of expand and build on this
character and like the depths of
struggle and strife that he's been
through all this time and so when this
happens when suddenly like after all the
things that he's endured all the laws
that he's endure to in turn come back
from the speed force and find out that
no one knows who he is except for Barry
and the Titans and his wife doesn't know
who he is and his kids are missing it's
a crushing experience and so as he goes
through here one of the things I want to
kind of do is I want to jump back to the
very very beginning of the story because
what this did is it kind of gave us this
poem that Wally was sort of musing over
and what he says is that in the
beginning when he and Linda Park first
got married she read this poem off to
him it was kind of like her vow to him
and and what he says is that this poem
that she read was really more about like
death and rebirth it was about sometimes
we lose things but we can always get
those things back it's only how hard it
is that we basically work for it and
it's kind of cool because what he says
is is like you know narc a character
that we talked about in the last video
kind of explained it to him you know
instead that it's all about creation
it's all about making things you know
it's not necessarily about literally
making things but about how love makes
things that essentially it's it was
really kind of a poem of hope that that
Wally West still has the chance to speak
to Linda Park he still has a chance to
get her back and by virtue of doing that
tracking down and then of course getting
his kids but at the same time that he
does this he basically snaps his fingers
creates a crack of lightning and
basically like brings back poison ivy he
essentially resurrects her from the dead
now the cool thing about this this is
one of the important elements to
remember is that Tom King's not pulling
this out of his backside right like on
the surface it would be easy to assume
that when it comes to poison ivy
remember she's part of the green she's
basically part she's a plant Elemental
is really what she is that was one of
the things that was established about
her through Swamp Thing that you had you
had like swamped thing so you had the
red which is people's ability to
basically kind of commune with the
animal animal side of the world more or
less or I guess the animal side of the
universe because I can kind of expand
that Beyond just the just the planet
Earth but then there's also the rot
which is basically everything dead more
or less and then there's the green which
is plant life and so while boys and I of
your physical form would die her
spiritual Essence would essentially
become part of the green which means at
any point she can be brought back and
that's exactly what what Wally does he
resurrects her from the dead and it's
kind of a cool thing because initially
we thought that that poison ivy was
going to be gone forever but Tom King
explicitly told us in the beginning of
Heroes in crisis on Twitter and various
forms of social media they're not going
to stay Dead Forever there's no reason
they would that the story is designed to
be self-contained it's designed to be a
set of events that take place and then
effectively end with things kind of
being returned to the status quo and
that's why it's so cool is because for
everything we see here while there is
the caveat that essentially none of it
really seems to matter there's also the
benefit that at the end of it all there
could be after effects there could be
things that kind of continue on from the
events of Heroes in crisis but that's
kind of where this big Revelation comes
from is because while Wally is talking
to poison ivy but what he says is I hurt
you I was supposed to help you and I
didn't I was supposed to be a hero and I
didn't in a time when you needed me I
basically let you die and the reason why
was because I wasn't really being a hero
and I apologize for that because you're
gonna have to see what comes next in
which she says what she says my death
you're going to have to watch me die and
that's the crazy thing because
essentially Wally West is in the present
watching himself die presumably coming
from the future or the past we don't
know
okay so originally I was not going to
cover this at least not right now right
like the most anticipated comic book
movie and I would argue the most
anticipated movie of all time is coming
out like tonight why would I talk about
anything but in-game that kind of
baffled me right like in-game's coming
out it's like yeah Rob I know in-game's
coming out and it's the one thing that
everybody's talking about can you talk
about spawn and it was like no
absolutely not but then but then like I
read heroes in crisis 8 and I was like
oh my God like I have to cover this
because dude here's the thing man dude
Tom King all right those of you guys who
don't like Tom King you're wrong and I'm
gonna tell you why you're wrong so this
whole thing was like a giant mystery
right like we didn't know who actually
killed everybody at sanctuary and heroes
and crisis like at least not in the
beginning but then it was revealed that
it was Harley Quinn but then it was also
revealed that it was Booster Gold and
the question was well then who was it
that did it right because if we saw
Harley Quinn kill everyone in the
beginning and then we saw Booster Gold
kill everyone then who actually killed
everyone it was a great big huge mystery
and so what this does is it basically
picks up with like Wally West and it's
the coolest thing because what he
basically says is like this is my
confession and I was just like wow like
right out of the gate like it's dude
it's it's nuts like I'm I'm I am see
this is why I like slow builds right
like a lot of people out there don't
really like slow bills they like like I
want the story told in three issues or
less which doesn't give you enough time
to really build anything up but slow
builds are awesome because the payoff is
usually worth it and like this is one of
those instances where it was definitely
worth it because when you go through
this he start like like literally Wally
starts talking about how like he'd been
there at Sanctuary for a few weeks you
know and he was there to recover and all
that kind of cool stuff but the funny
thing about this is he starts to talk
about how he looked at himself in
relation to everybody else and it's one
of the things that we weren't initially
made aware of what what Wally basically
says here is that with the nature of
sanctuary being what it was that all
these different people were there to
basically cope with the struggle so they
didn't do it now we knew that right like
we knew the basis behind Sanctuary was
that it was supposed to be a place of
healing and maybe your method of healing
was just punching you know virtual
reality drones and maybe your method of
healing was just meditation whatever the
case was all these different Heroes and
even some of the villains to a degree
who were trying to reform were going
through Sanctuary for the purpose of
healing themselves sort of healing their
minds healing their their spirits and so
on and so forth so they could go forward
having dealt with all this trauma but
for the most part what we weren't really
told and what really seems to be hit on
the head here is that they were all in
isolation and it's kind of interesting
because Tom King sort of made that
ambiguous right like all we really saw
with regards to the various characters
and heroes in crisis is like what they
were doing to heal we didn't see what
they were doing doing in their downtime
we didn't know if they were all like
just kind of hanging out and mingling
and talking and if sort of socializing
was kind of the kind of the healing
method which it would have made sense
because if you were Poison Ivy and you
were trying to like get to a better
version of yourself then what better way
to do that than to spend time hanging
out with Heroes people who normally go
through and save others but in fact all
these individuals were in a
compartmentalized space that they were
basically all isolated from one another
now again that allowed for anonymity it
allowed for them to be able to basically
function without anybody knowing what
their confessions were or what they were
doing to heal which provided a lot more
privacy and it basically allowed them to
operate with impunity in a small space
without any real consequence for what it
was that they were doing but when when
Wally started looking at this and when
he started started kind of focusing on
himself the conclusion that he came to
was that he was crazy well the the issue
here was that when he looked at
Sanctuary it wasn't a place where like
all these people were going to heal in
the mind of Wally West it was all just
the front like literally everything
going on in sanctuary was designed for
the purpose of making him feel like he
wasn't that bad and so what this means
is that for the most part when he looks
at all the other people they're
basically actors that they're they're
just to basically put on the show and
make it all seem legit and so he started
asking these questions why is it
Anonymous why is it that nobody really
knows what anybody else is doing and he
essentially decided to like feed into
his own ideology right and that's kind
of the cool thing here that's one of the
things that Tom King hits on right like
for whatever reason we will develop an
ideology right and then where the the
thought process used to be you know in a
previous age of humanity where the
thought process used to be here is an
opinion I have let me find facts that
either you know confirm this opinion or
conflict with this opinion and if the
fact that I find conflict with my
opinion then maybe it's time for me to
reorganize my opinion in this day and
age it's I have an opinion now let me
find the facts to support it and ignore
the facts that don't and that's exactly
what happened with Wally Wally started
going through and he developed his
ideology he's crazy so then he started
going through and looking at all the
information and we either twist it and
skew it or would ignore it if it didn't
support his perception and he would
basically say like this is all the
information that shows and I'm a crazy
person this is all the information that
shows that like all these things are
messed up and what he really kind of
says here is that in his mind that maybe
some of it had to do with Linda Park and
reason why is he says like for the most
part he was isolated and alone and
that's the interesting thing about this
because when you look at Wally here
while he does do something pretty
screwed up in a lot of ways she's a
victim because when you look at Wally
post DC rebirth for the most part aside
from the Titans there was nobody really
there to kind of guide him and how to
interact with with Linda Barry did to a
degree but the problem is that Barry was
he he really took kind of a cowardly
role right it's like hey Wally you
should go and talk to Linda and while
his response was no I don't want to and
the Barry said okay and then walked away
what Wally needed was to have his hand
forced what while he needed was to be
made to go talk to Linda park because
Wally didn't know that's what he needed
and that's that that's something that
Barry should have been able to pick up
on because Barry was his mentor and so
following this we see one of the coolest
set of events unfold in the history of
Wally West's character so so what Wally
ends up doing is he basically sits down
and he says okay I have to find out
whether or not this is a show or not I
have to find out whether or not any of
this is real but the problem with
Sanctuary according to Wally is that all
the confessions that are made are
literally split into like a billion
different pieces they're fragmented all
over the place and then just kind of
scattered out into wherever it is that
they happen to go but Wally is the
fastest man alive and so Wally's like
okay well I'm just gonna grab all the
pieces and and grab all these little
digital bites and bring them back
together again and that's what he did
Wally West was the one who recompiled
everybody's confessions he's the one
that basically brought it all back
together and then he watched all the
confessions and the issue is that when
he did that it broke him because he was
literally watching nothing but pain and
suffering for however long it took him
to watch and it basically warped and
screwed up his mind and the result was
that he it essentially kind of broke him
on a mental level now following this he
basically races out of the house to
catch his breath and then what he does
is he talks about the speed force and he
says that with the speed force people
look at it and they say yeah the speed
force is so cool he's got an accelerated
healing Factor you can time travel you
can travel to other dimensions if you
vibrate the right way you can do all
kinds of really awesome things but Wally
says that like there's a huge drawback
and a huge drawback is that you're
essentially taking your portion of a
multiversal source of energy and keeping
it confined into yourself and if it were
to explode out of you what would happen
and that's what happens here that when
Wally's trying to regain his composure
when he's watching all this pain and
suffering Replay in his head when he
triggers an alarm by messing with the
computer systems and everybody comes
filing out all this energy just kind of
lets loose he snaps for a brief second
and when that happens all these people
in sanctuary are killed and so the
question is what does Wally do because
he just basically killed everyone what
does Wally do after this he constructs a
plan he basically frames Booster Gold
and Harley Quinn what he essentially
does is that because booster and
Hollywood the last two who are in there
they're the last two who left that what
he essentially did is he he messed with
their VR systems so that when they
thought they were leaving they were
actually walking back into the VR system
itself and then he in turn modified
Sanctuary so that Harley Quinn saw
Booster Gold kill everybody including
Wally West and Booster Gold saw Harley
Quinn kill everybody including Wally
West and so following that he ran five
days into the future like after they
were done he ran five days into the
future brought himself back and
literally had this conversation he
placed a fake body basically like he
engineered an entire crime scene and he
did this because he was with Barry Allen
for decades right for like at least 20
years of his life he knows exactly how
Barry Allen thinks and with Barry Allen
being the CSI the crime scene
investigator that the Justice League
would inevitably call in the best one in
the world he knew exactly what Barry
would look for and he knew exactly what
Barry would miss he also knew what
Batman would follow up with because
remember flash has been on T or Wally
West has been on teams with Batman
before and so while he while he is not
the the best person to know exactly how
Batman thinks what he does know is how
Batman functions as a detective Wally
West tricked Barry Allen and tricked
Batman into believing that he actually
died and then what he did is he used
like he basically set up frames he
killed everyone and lied about it and so
following that like he basically said
like I had five days you know I had five
days to sit down and to create this
confession Wally West killed everyone
faked a crime scene tampered with
evidence framed Harley Quinn in Booster
Gold all for the purpose of trying to
find a way to basically escape a murder
that he made and try to find a way to do
something right to make up for what it
was that he did wrong and the only
conclusion he could come to the only
thing that he could figure out the only
thing he they believed he could do right
in order to correct what it was that he
did wrong was to confess to send this
confession directly to Lois Lane and
it's crazy crazy because what this
basically means now is that like Wally
West is a murderer now given the
circumstance in terms of how it unfolded
one of the things that you guys will
always usually always notice when it
comes to superheroes and in various
comic books superheroes and Marvel
superheroes in DC is they usually get a
pass right like that was one of the best
lines of secret Empire to kind of
Sidetrack here from from Heroes in
crisis that was one of the best parts of
secret Empire when stevel when Evil
Captain America was talking to good
Captain America that literally what what
Evil Captain America said was like Hey
like I'm not one of your Avenger friends
right like I'm not Thor I'm not the
Incredible Hulk I don't get a pass it's
one of these things where like I'll end
up having to do time for what I did with
Wally it's something akin to that right
like Wally is a hero and so the result
is that he'll be given the benefit of
the doubt if this was any other villain
out there immediately he would have been
put on trial probably sent to Arkham or
sent to some other prison Bell Reeve
thrown into the suicide squad like who
knows what would have happened to them
but they certainly would not get the
benefit of the doubt right like if the
Joker had done this or if like Harley
Quinn had done this like they would have
immediately been thrown in there but
with Wally it's like well but I mean
he's a good guy though so like we got to
give him the benefit of the doubt I mean
sure he did a really bad thing but like
we like him though so like it's it's
okay like that's that's literally what
it'll turn into and it's so intriguing
because it basically kind of throws into
the idea of like what happens to Wally
next Where Do We Go From Here Wally is a
confessed killer he confessed to his
crime what follows after this one of the
best Comics I've read in a long time I
love heroes in crisis it's absolutely
amazing
okay so uh you guys have been asking for
it so we are finally covering the the
conclusion to heroes in crisis also FYI
Tuesday Thursday and Saturday we're
covering dark Phoenix Saga uh so that we
can have that out for the for the
weekend and then we jump back into your
regularly scheduled programming which is
basically almost everything coming out
from Marvel because we have a lot of
catching up to do but um with heroes in
crisis number nine this basically
answers the question that everybody's
been asking why did Wally do what he did
how did it all unfold what's going on
right because with heroes in crisis like
we have had questions answered but it's
been kind of cloak and daggering kind of
murky and it's kind of been like half
answers and so it's just sort of like
all right like we need a definitive
explanation to all of this stuff and so
what this does is it initially picks up
with the arrival of Batgirl of Booster
Gold of Blue Beetle and Harley Quinn now
remember these four have been just
essentially like figuring everything out
at least trying to figure everything out
and under normal circumstances we would
assume Batman would be the one to
arrived to the conclusion about
everything but remember Harley Quinn and
Booster Gold were the ones who were on
the scene I and so the result is that
they actually kind of have an insight
into what's going on that nobody else in
the Justice League has at the same time
they were believed to have been the
killers and so they were essentially
underground and so what you had was
Batwoman and Blue Beetle who basically
ran up on them now of course Batwoman
running up on Harley Quinn was kind of
hearing the two together even though
they've never really been like direct
enemies Harley Quinn's more of like a
Batman enemy but also kind of an enemy
of the bat family right but like in
terms of who she comes into conflict
most is Batman that's kind of what we
expect from her character really
alongside the Joker or even by herself
when she's or when she's on a team with
Gotham City Sirens but the fact remains
that with Booster Gold and Blue Beetle
again this makes sense right for the
people who have been reading DC for a
while Booster Gold and Blue Beetle go
way back like they're you know
exceedingly good friends and so when
Booster Gold shows up on the doorstep of
Ted corn and says hey man I didn't do
this you have to believe me Ted Court's
response is okay then let's figure out
who did and that's kind of why we have
all these guys here and so when Harley
shows up they're immediately met by the
arrival of like poison ivy and this is
kind of a cool thing it's actually a
cool little moment here because when it
comes to Harley Quinn while we do see
the human side of her in the sense that
actually she feels emotion she cries she
she loves things like that it's usually
accompanied by like insanity or some
crazy set of circumstances we very
rarely ever get to see Harley Quinn just
be a tried and true person right and
it's one of the things that we tend to
forget that like at the end of the day
despite her her you know various
escapades with the joker and even with
poison ivy despite her dealings with the
suicide squad and so on Harley Quinn is
still for the most part a rational
person she's crazy but she's not like
Joker crazy right she'll like off the
deep end never to return to sanity and
the funny thing about this is that
poison ivy is kind of her anchor to her
sanity right it's like the one person
that keeps her from like falling over
the edge the two have been romantically
involved they were a couple up until the
point when like poison ivy basically
died now this is also a very big
Revelation here this really kind of
built on from the last issue for the
last couple issues and is kept going by
Tom King and is basically the idea that
poison ivy is essentially Immortal right
like she has like what she does is
something akin to like Voldemort in the
horcruxes right like so long as those
horror crushes exist Voldemort would
always come back the idea behind this is
that with poison ivy a part of herself
was put into a a flower and then that
plant that flower was planted of course
by Wally West five days after she died
and what that means is that so long if
she puts an essence of herself into some
part of the green then she can always
basically re-manifest she can return now
of course for those of you guys who are
coming into this brand new the green is
is just kind of a colloquial name for
like nature more or less insofar as like
plant life right you have the red which
is animals and then you have the rot
which is the death of all things more or
less you know like death itself to a
degree like rotting decaying that kind
of a thing the gist behind this is that
with poison ivy being part of the green
it means that she's literally part of
nature right like she's on par with
Swamp Thing and so basically by
establishing this again Tom King says
like so long as a part of her Essence is
tapped into the green meaning like it's
in a flower or a plant or something like
that and it's reconnected to the green
reconnected to like nature itself to the
plant aspect of this world or any other
then what it means is that she can
basically reconstitute her physical form
and then of course it seems as though
she has all of her memories intact she
recalls Harley Quinn she knows the two
of them were together it's a pretty cool
it's a pretty cool little thing and it
really kind of like adds on to the
existing nature of poison ivy right we
always kind of knew to a degree there
was an aspect of immortality there
witness didn't really know how far it
went of course this is when it switches
over to Wally West and this is kind of a
cool thing because you sort of have like
Batwoman you have Harley you have poison
ivy booster golden Ted Court who are
just sort of watching these two Wally
West you know encounter one another and
it's because Wally West feels totally
alone and this is when the huge
explanation comes this is when it's all
basically revealed that what we find out
here is that when Wally had pieced
together all these little bits of
information right like these little
tidbits of confessions and so on when he
experienced like this huge influx of
like pain and suffering from all these
Heroes he cracked and of course we know
that led to him just kind of letting off
the speed force Power and killing
everybody in the vicinity that part had
already been explained what comes next
is this idea that in Wally's mind
because he had killed all these people
what he needed to do was something that
would basically right the wrong he
needed an equally good thing to match
the equally bad thing and so what he
ended up doing was running five days
into the future grabbing himself and
then killing himself bringing it back
and then dropping it off and of course
as we know that that would spare him
five days but the logic behind his
actions is what we didn't entirely know
his initial indication was well I'll
just run back in time and stop myself
from blowing up but as he points out
with Barry Allen and the flashpoint
event we don't know what ramification
that would cause right I mean for Barry
it was keeping his mom alive right like
it was saving the life of his mom and
that changed the entire universe
something that's small that seemed
remote for the most part to be confined
strictly to Barry right like it wasn't
like he saved Krypton from blowing up
and he saved Batman's parents you know
and he prevented a Joker from being
thrown into like the the vat of
chemicals at Ace chemical plant and he
stopped Two-Face from being splashed
with acid it's not like he did all those
things right it's just he saved his
mom's life and that fundamentally
altered the entirety of the universe now
Doomsday Clock is kind of hitting on
that and saying well it really may have
been more Manhattan than like Barry
Allen but at the end of the day the
actions are very fundamentally change
the way the universe was organized and
structured and what Wally was doing is
he was looking at that and saying okay
all Barry did was save his mom's life
now we're talking about me going back in
time and preventing the death of a whole
bunch of Heroes we have no idea what
impact they would have on the universe
so he said okay that's done then the
question became okay then what good can
I do in order to fix this and that's why
he basically compiled all that
information all the confessions released
it to Lois Lane and then had her dump it
to the press it forced the hand of
Superman is because what it did is it
forced Superman to come out is like the
world's Premier hero right like the one
hero everybody looks up to and the one
hero that pretty much everyone trusts
came out and said guys what you've seen
is real it's not a dupe it's not a trick
it's not some CGI Adobe After Effects
it's us as Heroes confessing our darkest
moments the things that we regret the
most the mistakes we've made and
basically saying like we're humans we
screw up we feel pain and all that kind
of stuff we don't show you because you
have to look up to us and what are we if
we're emotional if we feel pain and we
feel suffering and we want to give up
sometimes and we do bad things if we're
not the people you've built us up to be
then we're nothing we're nothing
different than you and if you can't rely
on us to save the world then you have to
rely on yourselves to save the world
which can lead to Absolute Anarchy
because then suddenly everybody becomes
a vigilante you need us to be heroes and
you need to see us as Heroes therefore
we could not let you see us as anything
but that that's why we had Sanctuary
that's why we kept everything hidden
from you but Superman going out stepping
out and revealing all that basically
meant that like the world sees Heroes as
people and so it's kind of a fun thing
kind of an interesting thing because
what this does is it attaps into Wally
and it really kind of changes the entire
Dynamic of like heroes in crisis because
now it's no longer heroes in crisis now
it's the crisis of Wally West right like
I was I was a Denver Comic Con uh this
past weekend and I was talking to Sal
and he and I were running over like what
we thought about heroes in crisis and he
made that good point he's like it's the
crisis of Wally West because when you
look at Wally as a character that's why
this is so cool when you look at Wally
as a character all he's known since the
events of rebirth is lost right like
that that's all he's known before the
events of Flashpoint before the events
of rebirth that that Wally West had Jai
and Iris he had his kids he had Linda he
had his family he had everything that he
ever wanted right I mean in a lot of
ways he lived the perfect life that was
the cool thing about Wally and that's
why so many fans loved him so much right
like Crisis uninvented Earth happens
Barry Allen basically dies or at least
was supposed to have died ends up
joining the speed force and he's gone
for the next 20 years this sets the
stage for Wally to basically become the
new Flash and he spends the first little
bit of it under the shadow of Barry and
then finally steps out of that shadow
and says I can be my own hero then he
starts doing things like tapping into
the speed force he starts doing things
like Mainline in the speed force he
starts becoming the fastest of all the
speedsters he starts developing a new
set of powers that not even Barry had
and then it comes a point where he
basically marries the reporter Linda
Park then he has Jai then he has Iris
there was a point in time right before
the events of Flashpoint when Wally had
it all he had everything he ever needed
he had friends he had family the whole
nine yards and then Flashpoint happens
and it's all gone in the blink of an eye
everything he knows is is gone he
encounters Dr Manhattan we know that
from the events of Doomsday Clock he
tries to stop Dr Manhattan Manhattan
pushes him back into the speed force and
while he's stuck back there again
eventually he makes his way out when
Barry finally realizes who he is only to
come back to the real world and realize
the only people who seem to recall him
are Wally maybe a couple of the heroes
and like the Titans and that's it but
the people who mean the most to him his
children he doesn't know where they are
his wife doesn't know who he is he's
lost everything and so in this moment
when he basically goes to like confess
the things he's struggling with when he
can find a brief moment of reprieve he
kills everyone with a speed force Powers
it's like while he can't do anything but
screw up right like ever since the
eventual events of Flashpoint he's just
out of sync with the way things are
supposed to be that he can't do anything
right and that's the struggle of Wally
West is he went from being the hero to a
guy who can't do anything right and
that's what's so crushing is because
ultimately he feels totally alone and so
in this moment they're kind of stuck in
a recursive time Loop right because the
question is if this all kind of repeats
the same way right like Wally runs into
the pad or runs into the future five
days he grabs that future version of
himself he brings it back you know kills
him drops the body off and then
everybody thinks that while he's dead
and that buys in the five days in order
to bring together all the confessions
and then give it to Lois Lane who dumps
into the press and Superman has to talk
if it always plays out that way then how
do you break that Loop now this is where
Tom King kind of just I wouldn't say
screws the pooch but certainly takes the
story in the direction where it seems to
kind of take away from the impact of
everything because then what you end up
having is Booster Gold who Chimes up and
says hey just run to the Future and just
get a clone of yourself and like kill
the Clone bring it back drop the body
off and then you're fine you don't have
to kill yourself five days in the future
and so like that's it it's such an easy
way out to be honest it's such an easy
way out but that's kind of the funny
thing is because if you look at heroes
in crisis as a traditional superhero
story then yes that ending sucks and it
ruins the whole thing but if you look at
it for what it's supposed to be which is
a deconstruction of Wally West it's not
about the steps that Wally takes in
order to to win the day it's about
what's going on with Wally how does he
view the world if you look at it through
those eyes the entire nature of the
story changes and I think that's where a
lot of people struggled I think a lot of
people kind of went into this because DC
built it that way so you really can't
fault them for it but a lot of people
went into this like it's a great big
huge event and it's a it's a huge story
in like all kinds of crazy things are
gonna happen DC didn't really build it
as a deconstruction of Wally DC builds
it builds it as like this is the next
big event you know and it's like okay
and then you get into it and you realize
this doesn't quite work the way it's
supposed to now the thing about this
this is kind of the cool moment the
thing about this is that Wally kind of
sits down and says Okay so so I've done
this right like I went to the future I
grabbed a clone I dropped it off I
killed him and that's the body they
discover done and done the recursive
time Loop is closed things can move
forward there's still the question of
what happens to Wally what what goes on
now because while they killed people and
then he lied about it he framed Booster
Gold and Harley Quinn and then he forced
Superman's hand to dump a bunch of
information that really probably
shouldn't have been dumped in the first
place you know so what we're talking
about here is a guy who engaged in
murder and Espionage so like what do you
do with a guy like that well of course
Wally ends up being taken to prison and
just kind of dropped off in a Cell now
it's sort of left open-ended by by Tom
King in the sense of like Wally's there
but we don't really know what comes next
I imagine that question will be answered
in Joshua Williamson's flash right like
Joshua Williamson will probably pick up
on that and go from there either that or
Williamson will ignore it in his
entirety and it'll be like Heroes and
crisis never happen and that'll just be
the end of it I don't know how you treat
the story like it never happened if it
was confined strictly to Wally and he
basically managed to open the time Loop
and close it and no one knew about it
then sure you could just kind of sweep
this under the rug and say heroes in
crisis never happened I don't know what
you're talking about and call it a day
but like the confessions of the
superheroes being blasted out to the
world you can't really sweep out into
the rug there's no really there's no
real like coming back from that
but at the end of the day again heroes
in crisis you know like I said if you
look at it for what it is right like the
way it was designed to be viewed then
it's a beautifully done story but the
issue is that a lot of folks are kind of
let in under the belief that it was a
big crisis crossover kind of Grand Puba
event and and that was it so I don't
know I mean I'm curious what do you guys
think I'm curious what your opinions are
because I'm sure they're gonna vary I'm
sure they're going to be people who are
going to be like Heroes and prices
sucked and they're going to be people
who are like Heroes and crisis was
amazing so I'm I'm curious what your
all's response is what your all's
thought is I enjoyed it but again I
think the ending kind of took away from
what could have been a great story even
with it being a deconstruction of Wally
but nonetheless uh let me know what you
guys think if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
then make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later
peace